our following guest is the second most
productive redheaded quarterback to ever
play for the Cincinnati Bengals he also
had a prolific college career at USC
back when the Trojans were actually good
he went on to be the number one overall
pick and sent an NFL record by not
throwing a single incompletion in his
rookie season it's because he didn't
throw a pass in his rookie season please
welcome the man whose Heisman Trophy
currently sits in my mancave and he'll
never get it back Carson Palmer
[Music]
[Applause]
Carson looks like he could still play
joining us on behalf of the FedEx air
and ground NFL Player of the Year awards
could you play right now absolutely no
absolutely not I would pull a hamstring
running out for warmups there's no
chance if I gave you six months if you
gave me six months to Train I could I
could get two more games in when do you
know that it was time well you just said
I this is it the love of the game or is
it just the physicality of the guy it's
definitely not the love of the game the
love of the game I don't think ever
leaves you at least it hasn't left me
yet after two years post-career but you
know I think you start to realize it's
not it's not a one practice or a one
game where you go oh man I might be
getting too old it's the culmination of
going through the offseason to training
and getting your body ready for an
upcoming season and then you start
taking those hits week 1 through 16 and
and you start realizing at least I did
in my experience I started realizing
week for week eight week 12 I was like
and this is starting to really be
uncomfortable I'm starting to lose a
little bit here lose a little bit there
it might be time well I think it's time
after we saw you throw during the
commercial break because the arm didn't
seem that accurate and you were throwing
to make love and if we can show this
video here here's the Carson thrown to
McLovin this is a tradition like any
other McLovin takes on the great arms of
the NFL and he puts on his gloves he
puts on his helmet and you smoked him a
couple of times you overthrew your
receiver at one point well I thought he
wanted it I thought his breadbasket was
a little higher than actually was but I
was telling McLovin after that after one
of the catches he remind me a little bit
of Chad Ochocinco I just I had a
flashback you know just a that you are
underneath that shirt yeah flamboyant
Acula yeah I was gonna celebrate that
but you know it's just well then what do
you miss the most I mean obviously
Sunday as you miss the competition on
Sundays but there's there's a certain
you know comfort level you get with
being the face of the franchise the
quarterback of an organization the
pressure
that you have on a daily basis
throughout the offseason drawn on
Wednesday Thursday Friday practice in
meetings and obviously on game days on
the stage when you get that chance to
play but just that consistent pressure
and stress and expectation from
everybody around you within the
organization and on the team you missed
that you miss as soon as you go into
retirement it like that disappears so I
really do miss you know that that
constant pressure when you look at
Patrick mahomes that it feels as if he's
making it look easy it's not that easy
but why does he give you that impure
appearance that he's making it look yeah
he you know he just seems to play Kenna
remarkable reminds me a little bit of
Favre
attitude and mentality wise where if he
if he throws one in the wrong spot and
it gets picked it gets picked he'll come
back and throw two touchdown passes to
make up for it or you know that that
smile on his face that that natural you
know the third down run he had for the
touchdown
two weeks ago in the AFC Championship it
was like he was out in the backyard just
just playing and he kind of plays it's
not a reckless abandon but it's just a
he plays with with some some freedoms
and and you know just stress-free
worryfree and it's fun to watch and it
lets him go out there and and make those
type of jaw-dropping plays can you
empathize with Jimmy G even though he's
in the Super Bowl it feels like if they
lose it'll be some help on Jimmy
Garoppolo that's the position I mean
unfortunately when you sign up to play
quarterback you're the bum or the hero
and whether you know you play the worst
game of your life you know it gets
magnified and blown out of the portion
when you play a pretty good game it's
like it was the best game they've ever
seen so I mean that that's the position
there's no doubt about it
and people can can say what they want
about Jimmy and the NFC Championship and
throwing you know under 10 passes but
Jimmy's the number one seat and and had
a first-round bye and it's here in the
Superbowl so he's I think he's sitting
in his hotel room or on the practice
field laughing and everybody we were
asking a poll question
rather win the heisman or Super Bowl MVP
you won the heisman would you trade in
that Heisman for a Super Bowl MVP yeah
anyway and that's that's no offense
obviously the Heisman it's it's a
amazing honor and and you know a
tremendous honor but yeah I think I
think it's just natural
you always want what you don't have you
already gave away the Heisman so am I
getting that back it's on consignment I
think is what it does it cement it onto
a shelf where you just can't see I would
have to ship the entire bar to you what
didn't you do with that Heisman before
we got it because it had dust all over
it it's all banged up it's it looks like
it played in a game was a long time ago
I'm old I know but what did you do it's
the Heisman it was in my garage and and
it's just it's a very mature Heisman
Trophy even through its season drizzled
yes veteran Heisman I would have put it
on as a hood ornament my car if I had a
high spindle rolls-royce yeah Bentley
Bentley yeah not a Rolls nobody has
Rolls Royces anymore they do they do but
I'll get it back to you eventually
eventually okay you know what when USC
wins the national title I'll get it back
- are you gonna live that long are you
what advice would you give Joe burrow to
go to Cincinnati you know he's he's such
a spectacular talent I mean I I think I
think people have really kind of
overlooked him by talking about chase
young and some of these other guys and
Herbert from Oregon you know I think
he's he seems to be an obvious number
one pick I think he's more athletic than
we think I think he can run more than
then he's shown and and what you saw him
do with his legs and the SEC against
really that's he's he's full of
defensive NFL talent you've seen him
athletically take over games you've seen
him do it in the national championship
just dropping dimes left and right all
over the field and into tight coverage
you know he's
I think it's he's head and shoulders the
number one pick you know going going to
since II you know I've been there I know
how that feels you know I know you at
leat what at least went to a team I
think had come off a Twins like you've
got drafted number one and then Jon
Kitna played and I think you guys won
eight games so you had some talent there
I'm just worried that as much as I love
Cincinnati Joe going into that
environment with that ownership and not
having any talent I mean that's a recipe
for disaster for quarterbacks yeah but
the one thing that the Duke Toma has
done a great job since he's he's kind of
seems like he's been leading the charge
as far as the draft process goes is
there's been some talent there you know
whether the organization buys in and is
fully going after a super bowl and
really trying to win a Super Bowls
there's the other question but
talent-wise they've had some good
players I was fortunate to play with a
lot of really good players since now
just at the receiver position I mean
from Chad Ochocinco TJ Houshmandzadeh
Peter Warrick I mean there was and you
can go on and on there was there were
some really good players some really
good skill players in the offensive side
of the ball you still got AJ green
hopefully he says he wants to come back
we'll see but they're drafting number
one for a reason it's because they were
the worst team in the in the National
Football League so obviously he's not
going into an environment like Patrick
mahomes went into in Kansas City so
we'll see yeah mahomes went into and
already made offense of but he's a
behind alex smith with it that helped he
had Andy Reed there and then you have
you know those great skilled position
guys but you know you start to look at
that position and you know you just go
you can get overwhelmed quickly even if
you're on a good team or a
better-than-average team so I worry
about that with him Carson Palmer
joining us your favorite Chad Ochocinco
story that you will tell your grandkids
I don't know I don't have one that
sticks out in my mind I just remember
every time I stepped into the huddle he
was open he on one place
we're running 42 I so I'll be wide open
Jed there's gonna be offensive lineman
blocking downfield I'll be wide open I
mean that was that was that was an every
every play occurrence in the huddle
which I don't do you want that from your
receiver absolutely I never I very
rarely said Chad he brought that energy
and and I think you know as serious and
as big as the NFL is you still need some
jokesters you need guys that make make
light of certain situations call a
complicated play for us right now gun
Pro full voice line of scrimmage or am i
I'm in the huddle snap count I need that
and then the Semco I need you do Dan
Marino forms okay so like like you're
you're you're Chad Ochocinco in the
huddle and I'm giving you the play in
the huddle you're gonna give me the play
and then we go to line of scrimmage in
the cone okay
just a simple third down play would be
gun Pro right zip rip 686 Z over H Ricky
on - on - ready break
okay good flying scrimmage any good but
that's three hut hut hut I know but I
win on the first to do that I would say
it's on one and I would keep saying Hut
so that may be a defensive lineman would
would kind of back off go what's gone
and then and then rush the passer
Rodgers pretty good Rodgers is really
good at it yeah and Marino like it
sounded like it was pretty good yeah do
you want to judge these guys right here
Molly why is it green 19 I don't
understand that you pull like that
that's Aaron Rodgers average but yeah I
was a white 80 okay
Fritzi you want to give Carson one
her god I need a fill films was McLovin
you got 156 of Mike no no 54 is the Mike
I don't know Mike is how big house the
best one see do you really have to point
out the Mike linebacker it feels like
that's actually paramount doesn't the
center know where the Mike linebacker is
the Mike is always changing and
everybody up front needs to know who the
Mike is especially the halfback in the
backfield that's blocked what is the
Mike linebacker in the middle of the
three
so there's Mike strong side linebackers
of Sam weak side linebackers the will
okay seen you got one that's gonna
actually ask so what exactly is the Mike
linebacker yeah you guys talks about it
buddy so cool you guys talking you know
you get these analysts who just Mike
linebacker middle linebacker like double
whammo block like a gap and all that so
we let me come on you have a chalkboard
tell me about the FedEx air and ground
NFL players of the Year award so you
have voting ins for for fans
tomorrow at 3:00 Eastern you can vote on
NFL's Twitter page you can vote at
nfl.com backslash or /px
we're gonna hand out the awards Saturday
night right before the honor show it's
it's it's coming down to the wire the
the three quarterbacks are Lamar Jackson
who got my vote who had obviously
spectacular year Russell Wilson Patrick
mahomes and then the tailbacks for the
ground Player of the Year our Derrick
Henry who also had a spectacular year
and then Nick Chubb and McCain Christian
McCaffrey McCaffrey what McCaffrey did
was phenomenal you know catching the
ball run the ball but yes voting voting
closes tomorrow at 3:00 and FedEx is
donating 40,000 dollars for both players
and
to the USO and the USO program is a
spectacular program it helps our
recently retired service men and women
transition into the next phase of their
lives so 10 FL comm / FedEx and can I
have your FedEx number if I need to send
your Heisman back I'll do whatever it
takes not saying what you know are they
sending your Heisman back does she care
that I don't even know she knows yes
I'll pay whatever it cost the feeling
it's gonna take a while it might take a
while but I promise I'll get it back too
I promise okay and we don't have to wait
for UIC to win a national title because
that's not happening anytime soon no no
it's not next year all right here's the
great course in Palmer we appreciate
your generosity and thank you again
thanks for having four more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]